bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
dans tout nouveau produit que j'ai juste
là on va faire un homme boxing voilà la
bête c'est le voit web silverlight et on
va le regarder maintenant
huawei stade a fait vraiment très très
fort ils ont sorti plein de produits
hyper cool le p 20 p20 propre everlight
tout le monde a beaucoup parlé du pev un
pro pour l'instant j'y pense quand le
prendre en main et de tester dommage
j'aimerais bien un jour ça arrivera
rassurez vous je convaincs de ces quatre
sait pas quand on regarde un peu de
patience mais je vais la voir là pour
l'instant à parler du félin laïque parce
que le peuple ait c'est vraiment un
produit très intéressant et qui va se
positionner vraiment en entrée de gamme
dans cette gamme est vain pourquoi avoir
choisi de parler du pédant light tout
simplement parce qu'on parle beaucoup
des smartphones très cher d'être en
expliquant même une petite fortune
on parle pas assez des produits qui sont
quand même moins cher plus abordable et
puis l'idée c'est effectivement de
pouvoir en parler et de voir ce prix
parce que sur la présentation quand il
ya eu des vins prévint propre et un live
fois que le prévenu a été un petit peu
passées à l'as
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé d'un côté
c'est normal parce que avec le montre
qu'on en fasse le p 20 pro bien
évidemment il a pris toute les flashs
toute l'actualité toute la lumière et
lui le port il ne restait pas grand
chose donc ce contrat dans cette vidéo
c'est qu'on va l'ouvrir
on va faire un goksin on va regarder un
peu ce qui est dans cette boîte et je
tiens à remercier mon partenaire
iphone.com qui m'a permis de la voir et
de le tester
donc merci beaucoup à l'iphone et on va
donc faire le doxie go va l'ouvrir et on
ne refera une deuxième vidéo
un peu plus tard que je sortirai d'ici
quelques jours ou en faire un test
complet de ce smartphone voir s'il est
intéressant est ce que ca produits à
acheter est-ce qu'il faut se positionner
dessus et au final est-ce qu'il est
suffisamment cool
oui ou non à les lire voilà la boîte on
a directement donc cette jolie boîte du
pépin et à la brosse et y perçoivent
alors de goûter c'est parce marcel du
coup tu perds chat donc ils vont pas
nous faire un truc de dingue
hormis l'autocollant diaphane points
comme vous avez un truc avec le petit
logo wl un like comme on ne voyait rien
de bien 20 go c'est du blanc là y'a pas
grand chose un produit qui a déjà est
servi pour faire des tests directement
pour iphone points comme donc c'est
normal qu'ils soient déjà ouvert de ce
point de vue là donc rassurez vous donc
on va regarder un petit peu ce que ça
dit comment il est fichu
hop alors le smartphone cette voie c'est
vrai que tout de suite c'est quand même
un peu plus de six postes sur un produit
d'entrée de gamme donc on n'a pas de
jolies logement on n'a pas un truc qui
vraiment bien fait sur l'ouverture
vous avez un petit sachet plastique
c'est un petit pressoir pas se mentir
d'un côté c'est le produit d'entrée de
gamme donc voilà un peu ce père un light
voilà je trouve moi plutôt pas mal
réussi vous avez effectivement ici le
petit logo wl vous avez votre capteur
ici on retrouve sur le côté
le bouton de volume on retrouve ici le
bouton pour l'allumer et l'éteindre sur
le dessus il n'y a pas grand chose dit
ce côté vous avez l'emplacement pour la
carte sim ici en bas le port jack la
recharge le haut parleur voir un produit
qui se tient plutôt pas mal qui est
plutôt joli à l'arrière vous avez
effectivement ici le double objectif là
on regarde un peu plus on disait tout à
l'heure vous avez un 13 mégapixels +1 2
mégas titre avec une ouverture de f 2.0
vous avez un petit flash juste en
dessous lecteur d'empreintes digitales
qui a alors voilà tout à l'heure que
cela plus en détail
rassurez vous dans la boîte vous avez
hop on tire comme ça voyez c'est pareil
stocco les finitions c'est un peu cheap
hausse ici pour ouvrir votre carte sim
un petit guide de démarrage
le petit guide de démarrage ici où vous
avez plein d'informations ici la carte
de garantie hop là directement votre
petit adaptateur là si je lève
voilà mon père ton la up le petit câble
pour venir le recharger et écoute ce
côté là qu'est ce que j'ai alors la
question c'est est-ce que j'ai quelque
chose et là j'ai des écouteurs voit la
balle avec mon petit jack
voilà donc voilà un peu je vous le dis
on je trouve que la finition de la boîte
bon effectivement on va tous vont
économique on est sur un produit qui
n'est pas particulièrement cher c'est
c'est un peu cheap hausse voilà pas se
mentir
mais bon une fois de plus introduit vous
payez pas cher donc est ce que vous
préférez que huawei à mettre de l'argent
à faire des jolies boîtes ou est ce que
c'est vrai que face à un produit pas
trop cher mon avis voilà on n'a plus vu
ça de ce côté là on va aller plutôt
directement à l'économie
là dessus alors le smartphone en
lui-même on va commencer à regarder on
va l'ouvrir et pis on fera une prochaine
vidéo de test 1 donc on entendrait tout
de suite alors ici hop une petite partie
que je vais on le veut
pour le regarder comme il est je trouve
que d'un point de vue esthétique
c'est un produit qui est joli j'ai bien
réussi qui est assez élégant pas trop
épais ça va nettement 1645 g pour qui on
point de vue format alors j'ai pas des
mains de bûcheron
j'ai des très grandes mains je trouve
qu'il tient très bien dans la main on
trouve assez facilement lecteur
d'empreintes digitales
point positif par rapport au samsung
eric 6 à 8 et par rapport à tout cela
tous les autres neuf et compagnie mais
on parle pas de la même chose c'est que
vous n'allez pas les flirts et
directement avec la lentille ici vous
positionner de façon assez intuitive
voyez ce poisson à la main je tourne mon
droit et juste la ceas intuitif on
trouve assez bien la position
naturellement pareil pour les boutons
volume
ici on n'a pas donc la question se pose
n'est pas de ce côté là non je trouve
que voilà en termes de prise en main ça
fonctionne ça fait bien la faire j'ai
rien à lui reprocher de ce côté là on va
aussi le nov
que peut retrouver sur l'essentiel phone
sur l'iphone il dit c'est sûr beaucoup
de smartphones android aujourd'hui on va
pas se mentir on a un écran qui sait
5,84 poussé l'ipc du lcd format 19
neuvième résolution de 1280 par 1080
pixels
on a quand même un écran qui occupe 80%
de la face avant c'est pas non plus un
petit truc c'est pas non plus rires
c'est pas non plus du ridicule
le processeur ce temps kirin 659 octas
core cadencé à 2 36 gigahertz 4 gigas de
ram 64 giga de stockage peut monter
jusqu'à 256 go grâce à une carte micro
sd que vous aller loger directement là
il tourne sous android 8.0 oreo avec la
surcouche revenus 8.0 ça on le verra
dans la prochaine vidéo donc abonnez
vous y restez connectés mais bien
évidemment le petit logo ou wake est
déplacé embarras bon bah c'est pas mal
mais je trouve qu'il est assez joli ce
produit on va pas se mentir je trouve
bien je dis nous tous les points de une
batterie 3 millions terreur voilà
disponible en noir comme vous l'avez là
en bleu et en rose et le tarif ses 369
euros
donc c'est pas déconner donc on va
l'allumer et puis après on va s'arrêter
là et on passera la vidéo test mais dans
quelques jours aux petites vibrations ou
huawei salut mon lapin donc lancé toute
la sélection de langage alors nous on va
le mettre
est-ce que j'ai le français gilles
français ue j'accepte 6,7
la météo j'accepte tout je suis comme ça
je suis un mec cool j'accepte tout bon
le wifi on verra plus tard pour se
connecter les services du jeune on voit
envoie moi tout google voilà
bienvenu.merci c'est sympa nous voilà
sur la bête alors on fera le test dans
une prochaine vidéo mais déjà ne
serait-ce que là pour regarder un petit
peu s'il est cool
moi je trouve que en tout cas d'un point
de vue esthétique cette petite encoche
ne me dérange pas vraiment elle me
dérange pas je trouve que le produit est
bien fait bien fini il est sympa voilà
donc on va régler ça dans une prochaine
vidéo voilà concerne boxing du p 20
light dites moi ce que vous en pensez à
ce que vous trouvez que le produit est
cool ce qui pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter par un produit de huawei si vous
n'avez jamais été client de warwick que
soit le prix d'un thé d'impro pellin
light la gamme doolaeghe à dire avec la
gamme si la gamme ça y'a plein de
produits chez eux
il ya aussi leur petit frère au nord qui
est la filiale de huawei il dit moi
voilà ce que vous en pensez vous marquez
tous ces commentaires alors restez
connectés parce que comme je vous le
disais au début de la vidéo je vous
faire une nouvelle vidéo de test pour
regarder un peu ce que pétain light a
dans le ventre
est ce qu'il est intéressant est ce
qu'il faut l'acquérir oui ou non
donc restez connectés je vous invite
comme d'hab a laissé tous vos
commentaires suggestions question
directement en bas en commentaire laissé
des jolies pouces vous abonner parce que
on va parler toujours plus et toujours
mieux de teck
d'ici là soyez sages portez vous bien je
vous embrasse et à bientôt
[Musique]